first things first i wanted to play this
obviously because this is uh
there's something that i think people
around the this
this community this this age range
probably love uh which is remember
because we've even watched the
mortal kombat annihilation on fridays
but there's a new mortal kombat movie
that is coming out um it's for hbo max
it's just called mortal kombat
uh so let's watch the trailer now we're
gonna watch the trailer
and after the trailer we're going to
watch somebody that we're going to watch
a trailer that
was fixed okay so this was the original
trailer and then we're going to watch
the fixed trailer
so let's see that first okay here it is
it's a red band trailer guys so there
might be naughty words and fatalities
first learned about this seven years ago
on a mission in brazil
to capture a wanted fugitive
when we got there it tore through our
unit in seconds
the target has superhuman abilities
it had the same marking you do cole
it's a birthmark what do you mean he was
born with it
yeah that's what a birthmark means
means you've been chosen throughout
history
different cultures all over the world
reference a great tournament
of champions that dragon marking
i think it's an invitation to fight for
something known
i like him as scorpion dude yeah me too
that's mortal kombat that's pretty dope
i am it
these are your champions i'm sonia
that's kano i'm luke
name's jax
the fate of earth is in our hands
no matter how many of my people we put
in the ground
we will not fail kill them
[Music]
god it's [ __ ] dope i'm in i
you know i'm in right like i'm in 100 in
[Applause]
oh
didn't really like to get over here
should have been a little bit more
forceful
yeah i don't get me wrong i'm watching
i'm gonna watch the [ __ ] out of this
movie
i know it wins you [ __ ] beauty
[Laughter]
yes so it looks [ __ ] good look man
that looks really really [ __ ] good
i i kind of like the vibe it kind of the
old kung fu
movie vibe that they have i like all
kung fu movies you know
obviously there's not going to be a lot
of it's
it's it reminds me
it's not going to be grounded in reality
you can't have a mortal kombat movie
that is
but it reminds me of old kung fu movies
now
look great trailer couple things that i
think should have been fixed
number one the get over here has to be
more forceful
yes they can't be like it has to be good
over here like really
[ __ ] forceful and the music
i need the mortal kombat theme yeah i
wasn't too bad with the music right
there but i understand what you're
getting at
however balisong fixed the trailer for
us
so let's watch the fix trailer shall we
bali song did this so for those that are
wondering uh
tell me what you think of this one
[Music]
first learned about this seven years ago
on a mission in brazil
to capture a wanted fugitive
when we got there it tore through our
unit in seconds
the target has super human abilities
it had the same markings listen to that
music now we're talking
it's a birthmark he was born with it
it's not a birthmark cole it means
you've been chosen
molly's so good hell yeah different
cultures all over the world
reference a great tournament
i think it's an invitation to fight for
something known
that's mortal kombat
this is [ __ ] dope the music makes it
like 10 times better
jax
the fate of earth is in our head
[Music]
no matter how many of my
oh [ __ ] son
[Music]
get over here oh he fixed it
baby
how [ __ ] good is that yeah i mean
[ __ ] what dude that music the way he
he edited perfectly
it's amazing i'm going to give everybody
the link because honestly if i was hbo i
would get
i would [ __ ] throw some money to bali
for the edit even though he doesn't own
any
stuff but anyway and give him give
him the money that was [ __ ] really
really well was a
that was a perfect [ __ ] edit i like
his description
yeah yeah yeah there's a million of
these and now there's a million in one
but this one's the best one
i don't care what anybody says oh other
people probably just overlaid it and
didn't
hard pull out the music very very
very well done god damn that was good
[ __ ]